bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette édition du week-end de votre
journal nous sommes le vendredi 18 mars
tout de suite les principaux titres
depuis plus d'un an la capitaine valérie
kern a pris le commandement du centre de
secours de vélizy villacoublay
elle reste la seule femme à diriger une
caserne dans les yvelines nous sommes
allés à sa rencontre
alors que les regards sont tournés vers
la loi travail une autre réforme est en
cours elle concerne le numérique et va
aussi avoir une incidence sur le jeu
vidéo et la pratique du sport
nous recevons le président de la
fédération française de jeu vidéo il est
yvelinois et comme chaque vendredi
retour tout à l'heure sur les faits
importants de l'actualité depuis le
début de la semaine nouvelle
mobilisation contre la réforme du
travail
cette fois ci des étudiants et puis
travail préparatoire pour la réalisation
des fresques dans le quartier du val
hybois plaisir ou encore le test
grandeur nature avant la grande crue
centennale de la scène a d'abord affecté
à montigny le bretonneux valérie kern
ont rejoint ensuite le centre de
formation départementale de trappes
avant d'être voici un peu plus d'un an
nommé à vélizy où elle dirige une
trentaine de pompiers professionnels et
une soixantaine de volontaires c'est la
seule femme à diriger une caserne dans
les yvelines
williams elle l'a rencontré
alors je vais vous montrer le standard
c'est de là que sont contrôlées les
départs en intervention avec une
personne qui a affecté en permanence
dans le département c'est la seule femme
à occuper cette fonction
valérie kern a pris le commandement du
centre de secours de vélizy villacoublay
en octobre 2015
une fonction à laquelle n'était pas du
tout destiné au départ j'ai un parcours
assez atypique parce que j'ai commencé
en tant qu ingénieur en informatique et
en tant qu ingénieur en informatique
parallèlement j'ai je suis rentré
sapeurs pompiers volontaires dans le
département de la savoie
c'est là où j'ai mis le pied dedans et
j'ai commencé vraiment accroché pour ce
métier toutes les qualités humaines et
la rencontre avec les gens et donc j'ai
décidé d'en faire mon métier un métier
qu'elle exerce depuis 2008 dans le 10 78
après avoir été affecté comme officier
de centre à montigny le bretonneux
valérie est passé adjointe au chef de
centre de formation à trappes pour être
nommé trois ans plus tard chef du centre
de secours de vélizy-villacoublay toute
une partie administrative où on va gérer
le personnel consigne un sapeur pompier
professionnel que volontaire donc toute
une partie ressources humaines y aussi
la gestion
des formations en parallèle avec l'école
départementale
il ya aussi toute une partie de
relations avec les élus valérie est à la
tête d'une trentaine d'hommes et d'une
soixantaine de pompiers volontaires pour
une caserne qui effectue pas moins de
trois mille interventions par an sur le
secteur de vélizy jouy-en-josas et aux
loges en josas l'iphone à l'entraînement
donc ici mullings sauvetage d'une
personne qui seraient bloqués sur le
toit il ya un créneau horaire 10 heures
à 12 heures tous les jours donc
satisfaisant invention à fond en font
leur égard un poste rarement occupées
par des femmes en effet 90% des
effectifs des sapeurs pompiers sont des
hommes une fonction que valérie occupe
fièrement
donc aujourd'hui je vais remettre une
attestation
la parade ils colonisent carvin
directeur au chef farine qui a fait sa
formation chaque regard de vérifier une
technique post traumatique opérationnel
aujourd'hui remise de diplômes
un petit moment de plaisir au milieu de
toutes ces responsabilités bonnes
manoeuvres
nous parlons santé à présent santé des
dents comment bien se brosser les dents
et quels aliments éviter le soir
notamment ce sont à ces différentes
questions que les professionnels de la
santé bucco dentaire ont répondu à
trappes vendredi dernier et des familles
de la ville se sont rendus au centre
socioculturel annette moreau pour une
séance gratuite de dépistage camille
lambert je fais pas comme ça tu essaies
de faire des questions une fois que tu
as fait tout ça en bas je fais la même
chose se brosser les dents un acte
habituel mais pas toujours bien réalisé
avec l'aide d'un professionnel les
enfants font le point sur la bonne
technique à adopter mais j'ai appris
qu'en se brosser les dents
il a donné le sens du brossage ne pas
grignoter entre les repas bagages
brosser les dents après qu'on ait mangé
et parle trop de copains puisque ça
abîme des dons après cette petite mise à
niveau direction le cabinet pour une
séance gratuite de dépistage du caudan
terre organisé par la ville de trappes
au centre socioculturel annette moreau
c'est l'occasion de vérifier la présence
de caries ou d'anomalies une première
étape permettant de se familiariser avec
un environnement inhabituel c'est un
centre socio culturel au donc les gens
ont l'habitude de venir
ils ont confiance ils connaissent les
personnes
ils ont l'habitude de faire partie des
ateliers et ils ont envie de venir voir
et de se faire dépister du coup c'était
aussi une très très grande importance
c'est une bonne idée qu'il ya quelqu'un
comme ça d'un dentiste qui vient nous
voir et tout est comme ça ça nous
encourage un père aussi en même temps et
pour nous expliquer aussi surtout pour
les enfants
le dépistage indiqué aux patients s'ils
doivent prendre rendez vous avec un
dentiste pour se soigner
des démarches parfois compliqué mais le
centre socioculturel les accompagnent
cette opération que l'on fait c'est pour
essayer de voir des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude d'aller chez le dentiste pour
différentes raisons
leur demande s'ils veulent qu'on donne
le résultat facile des problèmes aux
responsables du centre social ici afin
que celui ci puisse éventuellement les
aider si a besoin dans leur démarche
une opération répétée une fois par an
dans les trois centres de la ville un
bon moyen de prendre soin de sa santé et
surtout de son sourire
un portrait à présent dans cette édition
du vendredi rencontre avec claude briand
et les maquettistes il résida plaisir
nous sommes allés à son atelier pour
voir comment ils travaillent et avec ce
souci du détail florane parfait patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images un
coup de pinceau assurer un regard
d'expert à plaisir claude briand a fait
de sa passion d'enfant son métier dans
son atelier il reproduit à l'identique
tous les modèles de voitures c'est
préférer ce sont les voitures de course
la période qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
les années 70 c'était une époque où les
voitures étaient déjà moderne mais ça
ressemblait encore à des voitures qui
n'étaient pas faites par des ordinateurs
claude briand est un artisan du modèle
réduit qui s'est formée tout seul depuis
quarante ans qu'ils travaillent dans ce
milieu
ici est fait un nom le bouche à oreille
fonctionne il réalise des commandes sur
demande
la première étape connaître un maximum
de détails pour réaliser son modèle pour
cela claude à ses archives
tout ça c'est une partie une partie de
ma documentation qui me sert à
travailler donc la gd
des livres anciens des revues de revues
lacets sport auto tout ça il ya des
clients qui me fournisse beaucoup de
photos de leur voiture donc je n'ai pas
besoin de ça
mais il y en a qui ne fournissent pas
grand chose donc ça me permet d'avoir
toute la documentation sur sur les
détails de la voiture le maquettiste
fait lui-même le montage de ses modèles
il récupère les pièces au gré de ses
recherches ou ses clients lui fournisse
toutes les étapes sont réalisés dans son
atelier ici c'est la cabine à peinture
celle ci que je peins un montage coûte
entre 50 et 100 euros cela sans compter
les pièces un hobby onéreux mais les
passionnés ne fume pas j'ai toujours
aimé le sport automobile alors le sport
automobile bien plus que l'automobile
parce que pour moi l'automobile c'est
juste un moyen de transport
pas très commode et un peu onéreux par
contre le sport automobile ou et ça
c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
vraiment alors c'est une porsche 924 est
ce qui a été
courcy fier on va dire elle était
transformé un retour de rallye
je lui ai fait en miniature on dit
toujours que les cordonniers sont les
plus mal chaussés mais bon en
l'occurrence j'ai quand même fait ma
voiture
alors que la réforme du travail
concentre toutes les attentions un autre
projet est en cours celui de la loi et
numériques déjà adopté par l'assemblée
nationale fin janvier il sera débattu ce
texte au sénat les 26 27 28 avril
prochain vote solennel le 3 mai
plusieurs avancées ont déjà été voté
plus de sanctions contre le rival ford
ou encore la formation des élèves à la
lutte contre les cyber violents
seulement rien n'est définitif elle si
les sénateurs à mende ce texte il
passera en deuxième lecture pour les
députés je reçois à présent franck
fontaine bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue
président de la fédération française de
jeu vidéo vous êtes yvelinois et il ya
un point qui vous intéressent
particulièrement dans ce texte dans
cette loi numérique c'est celui de la
reconnaissance du esport est-ce qu'on
peut définir déjà ce que c'est le esport
le lui sport oui c'est les compétitions
de jeux vidéo le fait qu'on puisse les
films et qu'on puisse les retransmettent
qu'il ya du spectacle qui a des femmes
des stars voilà ils décidèrent athlètes
on va en venir par rapport avec ce texte
de loi numérique parce qu'il ya un volet
de ce texte qui concerne lui ce porte
mais déjà son importance c'est quelque
chose qui se développe qui reste encore
un peu marginale c'est quelque chose qui
se développe depuis en france en tout
cas depuis depuis plus de dix ans et
dans d'autres pays comme la corée aux
etats unis c'est c'est déjà très bien
développée il ya eu d être une précision
ça concerne aussi bien les garçons que
les filles d'ailleurs wii balance est
unisexe le oui le il se porte alors ce
qui est prévu dans ce texte dans cette
loi numérique c'est tout d'abord que le
ministère chargé de la jeunesse pourra
délivrer des agréments par exemple aux
administrateurs de compétition
domination à dominante sportive par
exemple il y aura des exigences aussi
qu'ils seront qui seront posées est-ce
que tout cela va dans le bon sens ou non
oui ça va dans le bon sens notamment
pour bien différencier le
le jeu d'argent avec notamment les
cashprizes qui sont aujourd'hui des
sommes de plus en plus intéressante pour
les pour les civières athlètes
donc du coup il faut bien différencier
pour les associations qui organisent ou
même les entreprises se ce cash prize
que l'on ne confonde pas avec de la
loterie ou du jeu de hasard et du jeu
d'argent qui serait pour le coup
similaire un jeu de casino
ça permettra de protéger aussi les
joueurs je pense aux mineurs par exemple
où les problèmes de santé aussi par
exemple et de mon domaine de santé
publique des deux compétitions qui
durent très longtemps tout ça serait
encadrée maintenant baisse à voile à
protéger les mineurs aussi protéger les
cyberattaques eux-mêmes qui aujourd'hui
ont qu'à statuts sont souvent notre
entreprise rendent fiscalement
responsable tout à tous ces acteurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup d'argent
dont les taux ne voit pas forcément
puisque les cashprizes on ne sait pas où
ils vont on peut on peut sans doute ne
pas les déclarer ou les déclarer et là
c'est libre à chacun alors que demain
avec eux cette loi est public numérique
l'objectif c'est bien que l'on puisse
avoir une trace de tout cet argent plus
globalement quel regard vous portez sur
cette loi parce que maintenant jeux
vidéo et numériques sont intimement liés
avec le développement d'internet où les
jeux se font un réseau le
le fait de légiférer c'est une
obligation maintenant j'espère qu'elle
sera encore amendé sa déjà été amendé à
l'assemblée nationale on a émis un
rapport à un tu aimé briller qui était
en charge de la commission culturelle et
sur ce dossier on va on a été sollicité
pour encore y mettre un nouveau rapport
pour le avec l'amendement qui a été fait
par l'international mais là pour le coup
pour le sénat on est en train de
travailler on va le soumettre et
j'espère encore que le scénar va amender
certaines choses comme notamment le
chapitre qui qui donne pouvoir à l'état
de dire si telle ou telle association
est capable d'organiser des compétitions
pourquoi ça se sera pas positif
aujourd'hui des associations et ce
qu'elles vont tout on pouvoir répondre
au cahier des charges
est-ce que être trop directif sur un
article de loi aujourd'hui ne va pas
faire mourir 90% de l'ispor qui
aujourd'hui vit de par les associations
et on en a déjà pas assez au vu des
nombreuses demanderont le voit même ici
sur le territoire des yvelines par
exemple il ya plein d'élus qui nous
sollicitent pour faire des événements de
jeux vidéo sauf que il y a deux
associations dans les yvelines qui sont
qui songerait aussi accompagner ces
associations pour développer plutôt que
d'être trop stricte et deux volets
fermés en fait tout à fait c'est dans ce
sens là vous voulez voir les les
amendements le texte qui sera débattu re
je le rappelle ou au sénat la fin du
mois d'avril à partir du 26 normalement
le but de votre fédération
elle a été créée en 2013 s'est
rassemblée de fédérer les acteurs du jeu
vidéo français
alors c'est rêve reste tout ça au
quotidien ça consiste en quoi parce que
l'article de loi ça vous occupe pas mal
en ce moment il n'y a pas que ça mais il
n'ya pas que ça au quotidien c'est allé
voir les associations ré écouter leurs
besoins leurs attentes
des fois ça peut être ils ont une
association a été sollicité par une
municipalité pour organiser une
compétition pour faire vivre la jeunesse
c'est tout un week-end et b ça va être
regardé leur plan de salle leurs plans
réseau leur plan électrique
est-ce que c'est aux normes voilà leur
donne un coup de main pour avoir des
partenaires aussi faire vivre la
collectivité faire vivre le boulanger du
coin faire vivre voilà sur un événement
comment on appréhende tout ça et comment
le vit à week-end complet donc c'est
être présent en amont le jour j ai aussi
et aussi après pour les accompagner du
une mieux qu'on sait faire et puis vous
avez aussi des échanges avec le monde le
monde du jeu vidéo peut-être le syndicat
national du jeu vidéo est un acteur avec
lequel vous échangez le 9 mars ils ont
changé de président le syndicat national
des jeux vidéo
c'est le principal représentant des
intérêts des producteurs français et
pour nouveau président il a déclaré que
c'était le moment de faire surgir le jeu
vidéo non pas seulement comme un marché
qui créent des emplois de la valeur mais
aussi comme quelque chose de culturel et
artistique
ça vous plaît ça bah oui c'est le
dernier courrier qu'on a envoyé à notre
ancien ministre nomme fleur pellerin on
avait dit exactement la même phrase
c'est que avant tout le jeu vidéo est un
bien culturel et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui de par la starification
des joueurs etc
on a envie d'en que ça devienne un sport
mais je pense que le tissu associatif
aujourd'hui en france encore une fois
qui fait 90 % de l'ispor n'est pas
encore prêt à répondre à un cahier des
charges comme un vrai sport le
demanderait il a aussi parlé de
l'histoire justement ce nouveau
président du syndicat national du jeu
vidéo et il a dit que c'était pas
uniquement à un marché que c'était un
bouleversement sociétal au sein du sport
vous le percevez aussi comme ça oui
parce que tous les jeunes qu'on est
amené à rencontrer au quotidien on leur
parle de sports notamment de football
rugby
ils connaissent ils inévitablement on
voit que ça à la télé et ils connaissent
tous ce que c'est cuit sport en général
ils regardent tous ils connaissent tous
les groupes pratiquent encore un sport à
côté où il faire le rabat-joie
c'est les deux sont complémentaires
aujourd'hui si vous si on reparle un peu
d'aidé des objectifs de la fédération
c'est aussi d'accompagner les syndicats
de parents d'élèves c'est d'accompagner
les collégiens et les lycéens leur faire
comprendre que être un indice porter
c'est aussi
et on le voit il ya eu des reportages
sur des chaînes de télé nationale la
semaine dernière où en fait on voit bien
que les supporteurs s'entraîne aussi ils
vont courir le matin liger leur stress
que sur est sur une scène avec 6000
spectateurs physique plus des millions
de web spectateurs c'est aussi c'est
aussi stressant avec six branches
entières
voilà avec les enjeux du cash prize il
ya il ya pas mal de stress donc qu'être
à nice porter sauf si c'est jouer à sa
console tout seul à la maison mais à
tanis porter avait vu et vivre avec ça
et pour ça c'est ça sa demande d'avoir
souvent une bonne condition physique de
bien à manger etc et votre fédération
entend aussi justement dédiaboliser un
petit peu le jeu vidéo de jeux vidéo
delà du sport parce qu'il a pas que
l'histoire dans le jeu vidéo
les simulations sportives ya aussi tout
un autre volet de deux jeux de
reconstitution de deux guerres des
choses comme ça et que vous voulez qu'on
dédiabolise un petit peu parce que
souvent le jeu vidéo il est encore
aujourd'hui pointé du doigt bien souvent
oui il en faut il encore mal perçus
c'est ce pour quoi on travaille avec les
souvent les syndicats de parents
d'élèves et des fois si on a des
représentants de parents d'élèves qui
sont très réfractaires à l'idée de jeux
vidéo avant même d'organiser quelque
chose on va par exemple organiser avec
eux quand ils vont organiser leur forum
de l'emploi
comme beaucoup de deux syndicats de
parents d'élèves avec un collège ou un
lycée bonvalot d'écouter le jeu vidéo ça
crée des emplois aussi
du coup on peut participer avec vous et
montrez les métiers qui a dans le jeu
vidéo
il n'y a pas que de lys porter il ya
aussi ceux qui créent les jeux ce qui
développe ce qui encode ce que et du
coup aujourd'hui on travaille on
travaille avec eux dans ce sens là et
puis aussi peut être expliquée aux
parents qu'ils ont aussi leurs
responsabilités ne serait ce que parce
qu'il existe des petits logos sur les
jeux vidéos avec des agents fassent ils
sont pas toujours respectées ces âges
il ya des jeux vidéo mardi au moins 18
en tout cas largement des conseils et
par exemple aujourd'hui le pdis et c'est
déconseillé
ça fait justement un peu réagir sur
l'article l'article république numérique
ou ans est un jeu qui piquent 18 est ce
que demain on sera obligé d'avoir 18 ans
pour faire la compétition parce qu'un
jeu qui est pegi 18 quand on joue tout
seul et qu'on va tuer des innocents
parce que c'est le scénario qu'il veut
je comprends qu'ils soient pegi 18 par
contre dès lors où on va jouer en
multijoueur on s'affronte copains qu'on
de copains ou adversaires comptent a
dernièrement tu pues des civils du coup
il a plus lieu d'être pegi 18 il
pourrait être pegi 12 ou pegi 16 donc du
coup les images que ça peut véhiculer un
certain réalisme aussi et ouais facile
sur serveur film que c'est surtout la
psychologie on l'a vu sur certains jeux
ou par exemple c'était modern warfare 2
qui avait fait quand on devait on
arrivait sur un aéroport il fallait
qu'on continue tout le monde ya plein de
parents et je l'entends je le comprends
qui disait mon fils ne peut pas jouer
assez imbécile vous êtes parents oui
père de trois enfants c'est bien c'est
bien suivi ce qui était marqué sur votre
votre site parce que c'est aussi mis en
avant pour dire que vous aussi vous êtes
responsabiliser comment vous leur parlez
de jeux vidéo à vos enfants
mais c'est pas forcément moi qui l' en
parle c'est eux qui m'en parlent surtout
avec les copains qui jouent au jeu il
est copain qui m'envoient des sms pour
savoir quand et la prochaine compétition
aujourd'hui vous êtes le papa cool là
dans ces cas là
voilà l'image du papa cool mais aussi le
vis-à-vis d'autres parents qui ont un
peu de mal à faire entendre à l'enfant
ou que si tu travailles à l'école tu
peux jouer aux jeux vidéo ils ont trop
tendance à se réfugier sur le fait
qu'ils aient le jeu vidéo monfils lui
les addict aux jeux vidéo il travaille
mal et décollement fait le problème
n'est pas là wallemme sait il faut que
ton fils travaille à l'école et ensuite
il jouera et du coup en tout cas dans
sur le territoire jeu il ya beaucoup de
parents qui viennent me voir comment
vous faites pour pour empêcher les
enfants de jouer parce qu'à la maison il
ya toutes les consoles il ya tous les
jeux et vous avez les clés vous avez des
astuces si jamais vous avez besoin
d'action se tourner vers vous eu une
dernière question d'ici à 2017 vous
souhaitez organiser un événement
d'envergure au vélodrome justement oui
on a on a été invité avec eux toutes les
fédérations qu'ils ont pu inviter et
c'est vrai qu'on a bien discuté avec
vélo police et ont cédé ces trois mois
pour travailler et dépendre un projet
intéressant pour le territoire sous
médecins aussi à la région
appartement puisque c'est on veut que ce
soit un événement culturel et populaire
et l'objectif ça serait pour l'été 2010
est on fasse un bel événement pour les
dix minutes ce sera donc à suivre sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
merci franck fontaine donc président de
la fédération française des jeux vidéo
d'être passé sur ce plateau on poursuit
ce journal du vendredi avec un résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
comme chaque vendredi donc nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
le zapping des principaux sujets que
nous avons développées dans ce journal
depuis lundi le psg ou un établissement
privé ils ne veulent toujours pas en
entendre parler
les opposants se sont à nouveau
rassemblés pour protéger les 490
hectares de terres agricoles de l'école
d'ingénieurs agro paris tech au bénéfice
de tous donc que ça reste public
sauvegarder ce patrimoine ce lieu qui
est qu'il est rempli d'histoires 22
syndicats étudiants étaient appelés à
manifester aujourd'hui les partis de ces
syndicats de gauche qui manifestent
aujourd'hui contre le projet du
gouvernement socialiste
justement là c'est la gauche qui ne
renie pas ses valeurs qui justement
manifeste pour sauver ses valeurs on est
contre la précarité c'est pas un
gouvernement de gauche qu'on a en ce
moment quoi la quelle est l'histoire du
val ibuki vie c'est grâce aux réponses
des habitants du quartier que les
fresques vont voir le jour tout ça va
nous permettre à nous designer artiste
peinte de citer création de pouvoir
penser les fresques monumentales qu'on
va écrire qu'on va dessiner sur sur leur
mur c'est à dire leur peau et faire que
justement ils soient fiers de ce qui va
être réalisée aujourd'hui la page est
blanche pour nous donc ce à travers ces
témoignages qu'on sera en mesure de de
pouvoir créer et le 9 janvier dernier la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines procéder à sa
séance d'installation un nouveau
président et ses vice-présidents était
élu un collectif de citoyens a saisi la
justice dénonçant notamment la violation
du principe de publicité de la séance le
10 mars le tribunal administratif de
versailles a décidé de l'annulation de
cinq et délibérations dont l'élection du
président et de ses vice présidents
voilà pourquoi vous représenter à cette
élection qu'elle est un peu votre projet
l'idée de consignes et justement votre
projet voilà une petite précision je
suis également selon un chercheur n'est
pas médecin pourquoi je me représente
pour sujet des valeurs des principes qui
m'ont à mon sens doivent régir
d'universités françaises et l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines 2
je souhaite
nous battre pour ses principes d'autre
part j'ai une ambition pour cette
université
une ambition de développement de
rayonnement d'aller au delà de ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
les jeunes démocrates qui viennent de se
doter d'un nouveau président au niveau
national il a 25 ans il est yvelinois
originaire de viroflay il s'appelle
antonin a grêlé vous allez le voir à
l'image justement dans les bureaux des
jeunes démocrates du département il a
fait des études de commerce sa licence
il l'a passé en angleterre il est
aujourd'hui consultant en innovation
digital ça c'est pour son parcours
professionnel
sonam tibétaine et aujourd'hui elle
compte rester en france
si le tibet libéré je rentrerai et mais
sinon je ne peux pas si je reviens là
bas je serai tué parce que là bas j'ai
pris part à des mouvements politiques
alors si je reviens je serai tué
tibétains et afghans cohabitent dans ce
centre d'hébergement soit comme
demandeurs d'asile ou réfugiés
statutaires
mais avec le même objectif rester en
france pour reconstruire leur vie
sorti de son lit la scène a aujourd'hui
atteint un pic de crue de 8 mètres
conséquences sur la zone portuaire de
limay un camion avec nacelle s'est
abattue sur des camions citernes
contenant des produits chimiques ici du
chlore et du gasoil
scénario catastrophe est en réalité un
exercice grandeur nature un exercice de
dépollution que la france va mener
conjointement avec l'union européenne
hier soir à plaisir le corps d'une femme
de 54 ans a été découvert à son domicile
par son mari à son arrivée l'homme a
découvert son fils présents sur les
lieux selon des sources policières une
barrière entre les deux hommes aurait
éclaté avant que le fils ne prenne la
fuite ce qui fait de lui le principal
suspect de cette affaire l'homme est
actuellement toujours recherchés une
simple boîte en carton et pourtant lucas
s'amuse avec sa maman un matériel tout
simple qui aide au développement de la
motricité des plus petits
pour le coup la tranche d'âge de la
crèche c'est toute l'évolution avant de
refermer ce journal un mot des sujets
que nous aborderons à partir de lundi
direct à 18h tout d'abord la création
d'une aire de grand passage pour les
gens du voyage donc département un sujet
qui fait toujours débat depuis des
années le préfet devrait prochainement
trancher l'opposition est forte dans
certaines communes la saison des grandes
eaux à versailles qui va reprendre les
jardins royaux fait dès le 25 mars leurs
trois cent cinquante ans vous verrez les
images du nouveau spectacle qui sera
proposé puis enfin sport et handball
l'équipe de france des moins de 20 ans
s'est entraîné ce matin au complexe
sportif pierre de coubertin à montigny
le bretonneux les handballeuses vont
participer à un tournoi international
junior féminin durant tout le week-end
compétition organisée à plaisir le
tournoi important car qualificatif pour
les championnats du monde de 2016
on écoutait les réactions des joueuses à
la sortie de l'entraînement de ce
vendredi matin
c'est vraiment une foule fatale parce
qu'il ya c'est la première qui est la
première équipe qui
qui se qualifie donc voilà il est
capital pour la suite et pour la
continuité de du collectif il est
simplement un passage obligé pour aller
au mondial il faut remporter le tournoi
on espère vaincre et il est hors de
question que la france soit pas
représentée au mondial 2016 cet été un
mois du programme de nos confrères de
radio sensations pour le week-end
nicolas kirillovitch qui reçoit pour
l'hebdo politique dimanche et guy
malandain le maire de trappes il sera
question du budget 2016 de sa commune du
prolongement de l'autoroute a12 des
conséquences de l'élargissement de saint
quentin en yvelines notamment je vous
souhaite un très bon week end pour vos
sorties vos loisirs dans un instant le
7-8 week end avec mélanie poquet à
l'andi pour le retour de l'actualité
locale et le journal avec florent de
parfait